[Music]
akosia is on the line in orlando hey how
are you
hi mr ranci how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thank you for all you do god bless you
you too so
i have a question about my mom her
landlord is planning on increasing the
rent by 400
and she has no way to pay this for the
next year she currently makes about 2
400 a month
so with the new rent plus utilities and
her personal bills she's looking at over
3 000 a month
as her daughter i've tried to look for
many different places for her to move to
somewhere um cheaper so she can save
money and
buy a house for next year but she keeps
tossing them aside because she's very
picky anything that's not in her taste
she just disregarded so
how do i convince my mom that she needs
to find somewhere cheaper so she can
save money she's 54 and she doesn't even
have a single dollar in retirement
savings
she has nothing
but she wants all the bells and whistles
how old are you
i'm 26 years old
okay why does a 54 year old woman
need help picking out her new place
because she
she just needs help with those things
she's not too tech savvy like going on
websites and finding new places you
don't have to be tech savvy to know you
can't live there anymore
yes
that was a yellow pad and a number two
pencil
she's not finance minded at all i'm the
person who's always on her to pay your
bills on time avoid late fees i always
give her business ideas but she just
tosses them aside she doesn't see the
urgency in um
fixing her finances
uh she'll get urgency if you don't fix
them for her they'll evict her but
what's her plan currently
just to go into debt 600 bucks a month
she said she she's gonna get a second
job but here's the thing
my mom is a single mother she's always
worked two or three jobs so it's taken a
huge toll on her health over the years
so i really don't want her getting a
second job
and i want her to buy a house and save
money for retirement
but she doesn't understand that she
needs to find somewhere cheaper and save
money
i agree with your conclusion i agree
with your conclusions
and i appreciate you
loving your mom and wanting good things
for her
i am really confused why you're the only
adult in this conversation
with your mom
this is not your job
she's 54 freaking years old it's time
that she learned how to do something
you know yes so i mean i don't my kids
don't run around taking care of dave
yeah and i don't even run around taking
care of them they're like your age
so i mean these are supposed to be like
adult activities you shouldn't be having
to caretake your mom unless she has some
kind of mental disability and then
you're taking care of her i understand
that but she doesn't have a mental
disability she just doesn't give a crap
yeah it doesn't sound like she has a lot
of drive either what's she doing for
work exactly
she's a cna that's all she's done for
many years full time um
um
she worked three days and then four days
yeah okay so what would i do if i were
in your shoes
now that i'm getting over just being
aggravated at your mother for being
irresponsible okay
um i i appreciate the the journey that
you are on and the question that you're
asking but i the answer is i don't think
you can
do this for her
and i don't think you should do this for
her it's not good for you it's
emotionally weird
it's a boundary violation
and it's not good for her
so instead what i would do is step to
the side
and have a conversation with her that
sounds like this
mom
i love you
and i want you to have a great life
you have worked so hard
for so many years that it makes me cry
that you are struggling
i can't do this for you
i won't do this for you
but i will be your biggest cheerleader
and i'll even coach you on some things i
think you should do
but you're going to have to ask me what
you think what i think you should do i'm
not going to tell you anymore
and if she's decides to sit over there
and do nothing and get evicted
that is her grown-up decision it is not
your responsibility you need to wash
your hands of this
it is not in your you can't fix her life
she has to fix her life and even if you
could you shouldn't
it's weird and toxic
so your love for her and your
uh
honor for her for all the wonderful hard
work she's poured in and that your wish
for her
that that she has good things is
dependent not on you it's dependent on
her
to go get those things you can't do it
for her
nor can you just
nor do i have a sentence that you can
say to her that says who now all of a
sudden this lady who's never had any
ambition gets some this lady who's
chosen not to ever deal with finances at
all suddenly wants to go do that now but
what you can do is come alongside her
and just say mom i love you i'll help
you any way i can in terms of coaching
you and i'll be your biggest cheerleader
but i'm not going to do it for you and
i'm not going to carry the emotional
burden of you not being able to pay your
rent when you refuse to carry the own
your own emotional burden of you not
being able to pay your rent
does that sound harsh to you
no it sounds it sounds reasonable i'm
just very concerned about her health
i i don't i don't want to lose my mom
she's 54. she's not going to die from
getting evicted
but she she's had a lot of health scares
because of
working
so hard over the years she's always had
three jobs because you can't fix it
honey
okay she has to fix it
you're more worried about her than she
is
she's not worried about it
is she yeah
i mean on a scale of one to ten you're a
nine on worrying about her on a scale of
one to ten she's a two on worrying about
her am i right
you're right yeah so i mean you cannot
you know uh
if my kid doesn't want me to eat pizza
and fried bologna anymore
tuffy's i'm still gonna eat it i'm 62
i'm free i get to make these choices and
if my 30 year old doesn't like it
tuffy's
i'm still eating fried bologna and i'm
still gonna eat pizza
and biscuits and stuff okay
and dad i'm worried about your health i
understand but i'm not worried about as
much as you are i'm still going to eat
that
these are choices that grown-ups get to
make all change starts with being angry
about your situation until she hits that
point she's not going to change and
enabling her is not going to help her
long term but you can put your arm
around her and say i'm worried about you
and when you're ready to do this stuff
i'll be your biggest cheerleader
and i'll be your biggest coach
but i can't coach a wet blanket so you
mom when you get ready to move i'll help
you
but i can't do it for you